joe biden stonewalls all questions about
hunter biden's controversial emails
trump supporters are physically
assaulted in san francisco and
washington dc and we examine why
conservatives will vote for trump i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from prying eyes at
expressvpn.com
we are in the final days leading up to
one of the most contentious presidential
elections
in our nation's history what if biden
wins i mean
the market could certainly drop what if
the outcome is uncertain for weeks what
if we only have eight supreme court
justices what if the democrats try to
pack 83 more on there
you know lots of stuff could happen in
the future this is why you should
diversify your investment portfolio what
are you doing pre-election to shore up
your investments and safeguard your
future against the unknown well do what
i do diversify into gold with birch gold
just like i keep telling you wouldn't it
be nice to have that layer of security
whichever way the wind blows text ben
247-4747 one of the great people at
birch gold
will walk you through your conversion of
your eligible ira or 401k into a
precious metals ira where the physical
metal not etfs will be stored securely
birch gold they're my dudes they're
people that i work with regularly
i know them i trust them they did a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews talk to them
they're extremely knowledgeable they can
help you
preserve your savings give them a call
ask all of your questions get all the
information and then
take at least a little bit of your money
and diversify into precious metals it is
good to be
diversified across resources text ben's
47 47 47
open a precious metals ira today again
text ben to 47
47 47 to get started text ben 247
47 47 alrighty so over the weekend
fox news broke a story regarding the
hunter biden emails and
joe biden and everything else so as we
all know the new york post ran a story
last week
involving hunter biden's emails they
said that they obtained these emails and
a bunch of text messages from a computer
that he left
at a delaware repair shop and then never
came back and got
well this prompted the media to
basically claim that the story was false
beginning to end
they suggested that this was ill-gotten
gains that it was russian hacking or
something of the sort there's no
evidence
at this point by the way that that is
the case they just sort of speculated on
the basis of that speculation the social
media sites like twitter and facebook
decided to suppress the story
twitter later sort it back down but not
really the new york post
their account on twitter is still
suspended over at facebook they have
decided to reduce
the reach of stories that deal with the
new york post revelations well over the
weekend
fox news now reports that one of the
people on an explosive email threat
allegedly involving hunter biden
has corroborated the veracity of the
messages which appear to outline a
payout for former vice president joe
biden
as part of a deal with the chinese
energy firm so this obviously makes the
allegations a lot more serious
the the allegations apparently are that
it wasn't just hunter biden going around
and picking up bags of cash using
daddy's name
which of course we've known about for
quite a while i mean that's been true
fairly obviously on the surface hunter
biden has no qualifications for anything
of note
again his history is extraordinarily
checkered the idea that he was picking
up 50 grand a month just to sit
on the board of burisma a ukrainian
natural oil and gas
organization is absurd he was picking up
a bunch of money in china as well there
are stories now he's picking up money in
kazakhstan
it is not really a shock that to learn
that that was happening it would be a
shock however to learn that some of that
money was being passed through joe right
that would actually implicate the vice
president
in serious corruption it's the
difference between looking the other way
on a bad thing going on and actively
taking part
in a bad thing going on according to fox
news one email dated may 13
2017 obtained by fox news includes a
discussion of remuneration packages for
six people in a business deal with a
chinese energy firm
the email appeared to identify hunter
biden as quote chair slash vice chair
depending on agreement with cefc
in an apparent reference to the now
bankrupt cefc china energy
corporation the email includes a note
that quote hunter has some office
expectations he will elaborate
a proposed equity split references 20
for h presumably h's hunter
and 10 held 4-h for the big guy question
mark with no further details
fox news spoke to one of the people
copied on the email who confirmed the
authenticity of the email there's been a
lot of talk by the way about the emails
being forged or fake
not one denial of the authenticity of
the emails or texts has been put forward
by either joe biden or hunter biden's
people sources
here's here's where it starts to get
very very dicey sources told fox news
the big guy is a reference to the former
vice president
the new york post initially published
the emails and other controversial
messages
that fox news has also obtained so
that would really change things a fair
bit
if it turns out that that hunter biden
was being paid money and then half of it
was being held for joe biden now there
was another supporting text message in
which hunter biden was texting with his
own daughter
and he suggested that in the future
unlike your granddad i won't be holding
half your salary
which again sort of suggests that maybe
something nefarious is going on now
maybe there's a good explanation for all
of this
maybe it turns out that hunter was off
operating on his own joe didn't know
anything about it
maybe everybody's just misinterpreting
this and the big guy is somebody else
but wouldn't you expect the medio to ask
questions about this
wouldn't it make sense for the media to
ask questions about this especially
given the fact
that just like everybody else in the
upper echelon of politics joe biden has
engaged in some sweetheart dealings
before
as of 2008 this is a report from the new
york times in october of 2008 quote
although he is among the least wealthy
members of the millionaires club that is
the united states senate
joe biden and his wife jill a college
professor earn about 250 000 a year
mr biden maintains a lifestyle that is
more comfortable than the impression he
may have given on the campaign trail
this is as of 12 years ago
a review of his finances found that when
it comes to some of his largest expenses
like the purchase and upkeep of his home
and his use of amtrak to get around he
has benefited from resources and
relationships not available to average
americans
as a secure incumbent who has rarely
faced serious competitions during 35
years in the senate
mr biden has been able to dip into his
campaign treasury to spend thousands of
dollars on home landscaping and some of
his amtrak travel between wilmington
delaware where he lives in washington
and the acquisition of his waterfront
property a decade ago involved wealthy
businessmen and campaign supporters
some of them bankers with an interest in
legislation before the senate who bought
his old house for top dollar
sold him four acres at cost and lent him
500 grand to build his new home
there's nothing to suggest biden bent
any rules in the sale purchase and
financing of his homes rather he appears
to have benefited at times from the
simple fact of who he is
a united states senator not just amtrak
joe he was a vip so he was treated
accordingly by the bank said ronald
tennant a former loan officer who
handled the mortgages biden used to
build his house
the bank didn't give him a below market
interest rate a perk that has caused
embarrassment for some other members of
congress but
said ronald tennant we paid particularly
close attention to make sure everything
came out right so yeah
again there's just a certain amount of
cronyism that goes on
in politics it is also inarguable that
joe biden has looked the other way as
many of his relatives including his
brother and his son went around
trafficking on his name
the real damaging allegation would be if
joe biden personally benefited
from any of that if it wasn't just him
being sympathetic to family members and
looking the other way while they
participated in the appearance of
corruption but if he actually
participated in corruption remember this
entire story began
with joe biden denying originally that
he met with any ukrainian business
person
and then his campaign saying well maybe
there was sort of like a passing event
where he met one of hunter biden's
allies and hunter biden goes around the
world
basically telling foreigners that he has
access
to his dad and therefore they should
hand him sacks of cash right that's the
appearance of corruption
that's bad it is really bad obviously
and maybe criminal
if joe biden was actually receiving
money from any of those transactions and
right now the only thing we have that
suggests that
is an unnamed source of fox news
suggesting that that's what those emails
suggest okay so with that said wouldn't
you expect that joe biden would have to
answer some questions about it
well the answer of course is no the
answer of course is no he's not going to
have to answer any questions about it
because of course he's a democrat that's
the way that this works
so here for example is joe biden being
asked by a cbs news reporter about all
of this
he smacks the reporter nobody seems to
see this as a threat to the press nobody
seems to see this as
joe biden avoiding the question instead
the entire media the blue checks on
twitter
are very angry at fox news in the new
york post for reporting on the story at
all so we got three
years three long years of democrats and
the media
claiming at the top of their lungs the
trump russia collusion was a foregone
conclusion that the steele dossier
though it had yet to be verified
was filled with valuable information and
yet the angle
the media have been taking here is that
joe biden not only doesn't have to
answer questions
but that the new york post has to answer
very serious questions for having run
the stories in the first place here was
joe biden avoiding the question over the
weekend
mr biden what is your response to the
new york post story about your son
i know you had asked it i have no
response it's another campaign
right up your alley another question you
always had the
idea here is that the reporter is being
nasty for asking the question another
reporter asked biden about this
over the weekend as well and biden
simply walked away from it
and everybody else starts laughing you
can hear the other reporters laughing in
the background
as joe biden waves his hand at the
allegation and then just walks away
now is that how the media treat similar
allegations about the trump family and
their supposed
corruption and money-making off of the
trump name of course not
of course not okay so the new york times
has a long piece today not about
joe biden and his history or his or the
history of the biden family
instead they have a wonderful piece
today about
how the new york post is is chaotic in
the newsroom
according to the new york times the new
york post front page article about
hunter biden on wednesday
was written mostly by a staff reporter
who refused to put his name on it two
post employees said
bruce golding a reporter at the murdock
owned a tabloid since 2007
did not allow his byline to be used
because he had concerns over the
article's credibility the two post
employees said
speaking on the condition of anonymity
out of fear of retaliation
coming late in a heated presidential
campaign the article suggested that joe
biden had used his position to enrich
his son hunter when he was vice
president
the post based the story on photos and
labs and documents the paper said it had
taken
from the hard drive of a laptop
purportedly belonging to hunter biden
many post staff members questioned
whether the paper had done enough to
verify the authenticity of the hard
drive's contents
said five people with knowledge of the
tabloids and her workings staff members
also had concerns about the reliability
of its sources and its timing the people
said
the article named two sources stephen k
bannon who is now facing federal fraud
charges and rudy giuliani the
president's personal lawyer was said to
have given the paper a copy of the hard
drive
on october 11th giuliani said he chose
the new york post because quote either
nobody else would take it or if they
took it they would spend all the time
they could
trying to contradict it before they put
it out top editors met on october 11th
to discuss how to use the material
provided by giuliani the group included
the tabloid veteran colin allen
known as known as col steven lynch the
post editor in chief
and michelle got health the digital
editor in chief according to a person
with knowledge of the meeting
mr allen who was the post
editor-in-chief from 2001 to 2016
urged his colleagues to move quickly the
person said as the deadline approached
editors pressed staff members to add
their bylines to the story
and at least one aside from mr golding
refused according to two post
journalists
a post spokeswoman had no comment on how
the article was written or edited
now it's certainly possible that
somebody looked at the article after
having written the text and said you
know what i'm not comfortable putting my
name on this
it's also quite possible that the person
just didn't want to be the person on tv
answering questions about all of this
it turns out there's a pretty fraught
political environment
headlined biden's secret emails the
article appeared wednesday with two
bylines
emma joe morris a deputy politics editor
who joined the paper after
four years at fox news and gabrielle von
rouge a post reporter since 2014.
morris did not have a byline article in
the post before wednesday a search of
the website showed
she arrived at the tabloid in april
after working as so as an associate
producer
on sean hannity's fox news show miss von
roush had little to do with the
reporting or writing of the article she
learned that her byline was on the story
only after it was published
according to three people with knowledge
of how it was prepared
okay so the new york times washington
post
wall street journal they have reported
that they could not independently verify
the data in the post article which
included hedging language
referring at one point to an email
allegedly sent to hunter biden
okay so this was all from the the new
york times okay so
here is the question all of that may
very well be true is this the standard
the new york times holds
because they've post approximately 1 000
unverified scoops like dozens of them
and we we did a whole news cycle it came
up in a presidential debate
when the atlantic posted scoops about
president trump saying bad things about
wounded and and killed troops and it
turned out that everybody who was
present
on the record denied that any of this
happened didn't matter it was still
brought up
i mean we have unsourced allegations
from the steele dossier pushed into full
public view by buzzfeed
in early 2017. and there
literally there was nothing to verify
any of it nothing they ran with it
like the new york times ran with all of
it people around with all of it because
once it had been
put out there the story began became not
how it was obtained
but then it was put out there in the
first place it was the right that
started focusing on
on how it was obtained it was the right
that said okay where did the steele
dossier come from
why are we all talking about it who
gathered it in the first place and that
turned into so-called
russiagate right that turned into the
the whole sort of
spygate scandal now what does that say
well it says two things one it is
certainly fair for the new york times to
ask where all of this stuff came from
but two it does demonstrate their
political leanings right
it was the right that uncovered spygate
in the aftermath of russiagate
well it was the left that is now pushing
into where did the laptop come from and
no
and people are treating this story as
quote unquote debunked even though
again neither joan or hunter have
actually denied that the emails and
texts are real
and in fact in new york post in order to
establish the bona fides of the texts
they've actually put out a bunch of
texts that make joe biden look pretty
sympathetic right there are a bunch of
texts that came out over the weekend
in which joe biden was texting his son
hunter while hunter was in rehab and
they're very sympathetic
they make joe look really warm like a
good dad okay so
either they're all real or they ain't
real but we really don't have any
information that they ain't real at this
point there's yet to be
a full-on denial that these things are
real or any explanation of what it means
to hold 10 in trust for
for the big guy or what it meant when
hunter told his daughter
that his dad held half of his salary or
whatever
the new york post points this out in an
editorial today they have a piece
about to say much of the push to ignore
the post drop of hunter biden's emails
censors on the charge that it's all
unverified the claim is more excuse than
truth
first a host of media outlets have now
interviewed the company repair gut the
computer repair guy
who provided the data at the heart of
these exposes he said exactly what we've
reported from the start about how the
laptop came into his possession
second neither hunter nor joe has ever
questioned that the fact that the drive
is real
they merely dismiss the entire line of
questioning while charging the post has
an agenda
in presenting it to the world third
we've published emails and pictures most
of which have nothing to do with ukraine
or china that contain an extraordinary
level of detail is all of that
fabricated
the biden campaign's response notably is
not that an email from a barisma
official thanking hunter for an
introduction to his father isn't real
it's that said meeting doesn't show up
on joe's official schedules pressed by
politico the campaign acknowledged they
couldn't say for certain if joe biden
had met him casually
it's particularly rich that the new york
times has fixated on the unverified
excuse since
been must since it's spent much of the
trump era offering supposed dirt from
anonymous sources which by definition
makes the info unverifiable this of
course
is exactly right and exactly true so the
fact that the media wish to ignore the
story
is evidence more about what the media's
prior biases are
than about the story itself senator ron
johnson for his part remember the senate
intelligence committee
he says we are seeing more and more
validation that the hunter biden emails
are true here's the senator from
wisconsin
what we're finding is we're finding more
and more validation that these emails
are true
so you got some one one of the
recipients on that email chain has
has told fox news that yeah that's
that's a true email
now these these other emails that
breitbart's breaking from
bevan cooney is the co-conspirator the
man who's in jail right now
it's totally separate email server
totally separate emails that also are
starting to paint a picture
of the corruption the the vast web of
connections in
that the hunter biden his firms devin
archer were involved in
okay so um you know obviously this
deserves a little bit more
scrutiny remember it was just a few
months back that adam schiff said that
hunter biden under no circumstances
should be called as a witness
in the entire ukrainian investigation
even the republicans were clamoring for
it
republicans can for instance call on
hunter biden
this isn't like some fantasy football
trade as i said yesterday this
isn't we'll offer you this if you'll
give us that we'll offer you
a witness that is irrelevant and
immaterial who has no relevant testimony
but a witness that will allow us to
smear a presidential candidate
righty so this has been highly political
from the start there's a reason the
democrats don't want to talk about it
that makes perfect sense
now again does this mean that the story
itself is
utterly well substantiated in every
possible way
i have no evidence that's the case i i i
don't know you don't know
what i do know is that nobody seems to
be willing to hold biden's feet to the
fire he's been doing these long
interviews and nobody is asking him
these questions he's being asked about
it on the tarmac where he promptly
rips into the reporter for asking what
is a very simple and predictable
question
and meanwhile this election just gets
more and more contentious in every
possible way
violence broke out over the weekend
against trump supporters in both
washington dc and san francisco we'll
get to that in just one second first
our founding fathers knew the american
people are the ultimate guardians of
their own liberty
this is why they created the second
amendment to secure every american's
fundamental human right to protect
themselves their family and their
community we've watched in the past few
months
as violence has broken out in major
cities around the country gun sales are
through the roof there is a reason
for that and if you're going to own a
gun to protect yourself protect your
rights
if you're a responsible gun owner you
should have a gun that works for you
i mean a gun that really works i'm
talking about bravo company
manufacturing bravo company was started
in the garage marine veteran
of the us marine corps in heartland
wisconsin the people at bravo company
mfg
support the right of responsible private
citizens to have the access and ability
to employ the same tools as civilian law
enforcement as a means of defending
ourselves our loved ones our communities
and our freedoms should a threatening
situation ever rise
bravo company manufacturing is not a
sporting arms company they design
engineer and manufacture life-saving
equipment
bcm assumes that when a rifle leaves
their shop it will be used in a life or
death situation by a responsible citizen
law enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas quality is indeed of utmost
value to them every component
of a bcm rifle is hand assembled and
tested by americans in heartland
wisconsin
to a life-saving standard they're making
guns not for target shooting not for
hunting they're making it in case you
god forbid have to use it to learn more
about bravo company manufacturing head
on over to bravocompanymfg.com you can
discover more about their products
special offers upcoming news that is
bravocompanymfg.com if you need more
convincing find out even more about bcm
and the awesome people who make their
products at youtube.com
bravocompanyusa again that's youtube.com
bravocompanyusa okay well this election
continues to grow more and more
contentious
especially i think that is worth noting
that the the
there seems to be a widespread
perception among folks on the left
that donald trump is as the satanic
incredibly evil figure that if trump
goes away everything in the united
states gets better
that if trump goes away then we have
this great
coming together covid ends the skies
shine forth the beautiful new sun
not true there are grave underlying
issues these issues predated trump
frankly the country in terms of social
comedy
in terms in terms of the social fabric
the country was much better off in
at the very beginning of 2009 right
after obama was elected but before
obama actually became who he became over
the course of his terms
and the the the problems that have been
ripping america apart during the trump
era did not start during the trump year
they started during the obama era the
trump era was largely a response
to them and they're not going to go away
if trump goes away
this is why you're seeing the kind of
violence that you are seeing against
trump supporters
again if this were violence against
biden supporters by trump supporters you
know it would be front-page news it is
not therefore it is not
this happened this was an altercation
that happened
in in san francisco there's a black man
in san francisco who's protecting people
who are marching for trump from
presumably members of antifa uh and
other violent protesters
uh and um and this guy got his front
teeth knocked out here's a little bit of
video of the incident
i mean the guy's literally just standing
there and they're trying to walk away
and these
these jackasses in black masks come up
to them and just start punching them
directly in the face
i mean that's absurd it's absurd how is
this acceptable in civil society the
answer is it's not
but when you say it's okay to punch a
nazi and then you define everybody you
don't like as a nazi it becomes very
easy for this to happen meanwhile
reportedly in washington dc this is
according to the post-millennial
a female trump supporter was allegedly
attacked and hospitalized by women's
march and black lives matter activists
after she participated in a pro-trump
rally isabella maria deluca whose bio
identifies her as a turning point usa
ambassador posted images of her injuries
while recovering at a local hospital
apparently she is outreach director for
the republicans for national renewal
which is a pro-trump
organization a breitbart news reporter
attending the event captured footage of
deluca waving a trump flag and shouting
four more years earlier
in the day de luca says that she was
assaulted by an older female she said
the first woman was a white older woman
she had glasses on a glittery bedazzle
black lives matter shirt
she liked she could have been my grandma
honestly according to deluca a younger
assailant then grabbed
luca's pro-trump flag when she tried to
grab it back the woman allegedly punched
and choked her
deluca said she felt reluctant to defend
herself due to the advanced age of her
attacker but was determined to retrieve
the flag
when it was snatched deluca told the
publication a younger female black lives
matter supporter assisted the older
woman who had initially assaulted her by
hitting
pushing and punching de luca apparently
she was treated with a cervical collar
due to her to her head and neck injuries
and said she was suffering from blurry
vision and dizziness
due to the impact and we've seen this
sort of stuff fairly routinely across
the country
you know people who are wearing maga
hats and this is treated as though they
are wearing a swastika on their hats and
therefore people are being punched
and honestly the mainstream left may not
be in favor of the violence but they're
certainly in favor of this basic idea
which is that if you vote for trump
if you consider voting for trump you are
evil it's one of the reasons why i think
the left is so fearful about the polling
right now
because when you castigate anybody who
possibly would vote for trump as an
emissary of satan
it turns out they stopped telling
pollsters that they're going to vote for
trump and so there is this great fear
out there that there's this enormous
silent trump vote now that may or may
not be true it would have to be
incredibly enormous to overcome the sort
of barriers to election that trump is
showing in the polls
right now the polls are narrowing just
slightly there's an ibd tipped poll
today out
showing that trump is down six
nationally if trump gets down to about
down four nationally then it starts to
look like a very very competitive race
again
and indeed the gap has started to narrow
a little bit that's not a shock it
usually does
in the very lead up to the election but
the kind of language that is used by
typical mainstream members of the left
is indicative of their thought process
when it comes to
how trump supporters are to be viewed
and it is specifically because of that
that i think trump has such a high level
of support among republicans among other
reasons
which is if you suggest that everybody
who supports conservative viewpoints
is the equivalent of president trump
like they treated romney and they
treated trump
kind of the same way and so a lot of
republicans really resonate to the trump
line it's not about me it's about you
right the reason they don't hate me they
don't hate you because they hate me they
hate me because they hate you
right i am just a stand-in for their
hatred of you i'm just the the face
that they put on their hatred of you
many americans who disagree with the
wild left agenda
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that if
you've got male pattern baldness running
in your family
you want to avoid that fate but there's
really only one way to avoid that fate
and that is you need to get started with
keep so i have male pattern baldness it
does run
on both sides of my family actually and
that is why i've been using keeps for
quite a while two out of three dudes
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left
you just have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online get hair loss medication
delivered right to your home
they make it easy they deliver your
medication every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and those awkward doctor visits
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there
you may have tried them before probably
never for this price prevention is key
keeps treatments typically take between
four to six months to see results it's
important to act fast because
you got to stop that hair from going
away the faster you start the more hair
you will save
there's a reason why keeps has more
five-star reviews than any of the
competitors
and more than a hundred thousand men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com
ben to receive your first month of
treatment for free that is k-e-p-s
dot com slash ben keeps.com ben
says i say the the hatred for trump
supporters
does translate into a love of trump on
the part of many people
on the right the radicalism of the left
drives a lot of people
to the right and also drives them to be
silent about the fact that they are on
the right because they're afraid of the
consequences socially for saying they're
on the right
and there are people on the left who
embrace this robert reich
the former secretary of labor in the
clinton administration a wild leftist
he tweeted out over the weekend quote
when this nightmare is over we need a
truth and reconciliation commission
it would raise trump's lies comfort
those who have been harmed by his
hatefulness and name
every official politician executive and
media mogul whose greed and cowardice
enabled this catastrophe
so in other words every single person in
a position of power who backed trump or
said a kind word about trump
would apparently be listed by robert
reich by a government commission
and then those people would be targeted
for destruction that's his idea of a
truth and reconciliation
commission again when he when he says
truth and reconciliation commission he
says what he's talking about
is the post-apartheid truth and
reconciliation commission of south
africa
yeah the difference is that that was
post-apartheid this is not actually an
apartheid state it's not anything
remotely close to an apartheid state the
united states of america
nelson mandela became the leader of
south africa
at the end of apartheid barack obama was
elected president of the united states
because there was no apart
there is no apartheid there was
apartheid in the united states
in the 1950s there is no apartheid in
the united states circa 2020.
the idea of a truth and reconciliation
commission in which we all come together
to examine the great evil of trump is
such a bizarre and insane notion but i
think that there are a lot of people on
the left to agree with this
there are a lot of people on the left
who agree that half of america is
irredeemably evil and racist
and that we need some sort of
reconciliation commission to wipe this
off our hearts
it's like the post-nazi era we need a
denotification program for anybody who
is conservative
we need a denotification program for
anybody who served in the trump
administration
and that's because america is so
endemically evil on every level
and this would explain the general
perception on race that is promoted by
the left
if you believe that your enemies are
truly evil if you believe that your
enemies stand in favor of
racial apartheid and that everybody who
disagrees with you
is some sort of sick xenophobic racist
well that allows you to do whatever you
want you can punch people in the streets
you can push louis veracon over the
weekend there was yet another
sop piece to louis farrakhan by a person
named natalie hopkinson an author and
associate professor at howard
university's department of communication
culture and media studies talking about
the wonders of louis farrakhan overt
anti-semite
you want to talk about somebody who
hates gay people louis farrakhan hates
gay people
according to this new york times piece
just over 25 years ago louis farrakhan
the head of the nation of islam
realized he needed help in his exotic
quest to summon a million black men to
the national mall
a key supporter of the event was marion
barry who had just returned to the
washington's mayor's office after a sin
in federal prison
farrakhan wanted mrs missberry the first
lady cora masters berry
to work in electoral magic on the black
men who hoped to join him on the
national mall
in 1995 this piece goes on and on about
the wonders of the million man march
and the genius of louis farrakhan and
what a nice guy louis farrakhan was
it goes on and all of this is justified
because of course america is endemically
evil
not only that it turns out that if you
oppose louis farrakhan we can also
condemn you as evil the author of this
piece a person in
again natalie hopkinson she denounced
offended jews as close people who have
become white for their privilege
which is pretty amazing they said people
who have become white should not be
lecturing black people about oppression
that's the way america is now viewed
people who have become white now i
wasn't aware that you could quote
unquote become white apparently you can
apparently the way that you quote
unquote become white
is if you are no longer perceived by the
white superstructure
as a person of minority heritage what
that really says
is that the way we are now going to
judge people as to whether they're a
minority or not
is based on level of lack of success
which is an awfully racist way
to look at people who are black or
hispanic
i mean because again race is not
malleable if if you're saying now that
race is malleable based on level of
success in american society what you're
really doing is saying that that black
people and hispanic people are somehow
incapable of success which of course is
a great
racist lie but that that
notion is being promoted and actively
promoted
and by the way actively promoted in many
cases by the state
an article from nbc san diego over the
weekend students will no longer be
graded based on a yearly average
in the san diego unified school district
or on how late they turn in assignments
the san diego unified school district is
overhauling the way it grades its
students
board members say the changes are part
of a larger effort to combat racism
according to the san diego unified
school district vice president richard
barrera this is part of our honest
reckoning as a school district
if we're going to be an anti-racist
school district we have to confront
practices like this that have gone on
for years and years oh you mean
practices like grades
you mean practices like you need to turn
in your work on time
this is the length to which we have gone
to declare that americans are racist and
america is racist
so connect all of these ideas right we
now live in an america
where anti-racism is the order of the
day ibrahmax kennedy style robin
d'angelo style anti-racism
is the new prevailing ideology that
ideology says that america is deeply
evil
that if you don't agree that america is
deeply evil it's because you're a racist
and also if you're a racist we should
have a truth and reconciliation
commission
according to robert reich always just
punch you in the face if you're walking
on the streets and the way that we can
tell
is because you're wearing a trump hat
what do you think that's going to do you
think that might drive a silent trump
vote you think it may create
an impetus for people to vote against
this garbage people should vote against
this garbage it's garbage
i mean again just because black and
hispanic students apparently
are underperforming in the san diego
unified school district does not mean
that grades are the problem the grades
themselves are the problem this is no
less racist and horrific than that
ridiculous
post put up by the national museum of
african-american culture that suggested
that timeliness hard work and deferred
gratification were white qualities
a notion with which actual races like
david duke agree
according to nbc san diego according to
data presented by the district under the
old grading system
teachers fail minority students more
than white students a lot more
during the first semester of last year
30 percent of all drf grades were given
to english learners
1 in 4 25 of failing marks went to
students with disabilities
by ethnicity 23 went to native americans
another 23 percent went to hispanics and
or dia of drf grades went to black
students but just seven percent of
failing marks went to white students
so they've decided to get rid of grades
academic grades will now focus on
mastery of the material not a yearly
average which board members say
penalizes students who get a slow start
or who struggle at points throughout the
year
so in other words if you stink at math
at the beginning of the year and then
you're
okay at math at the end of the year then
the fact that you were terrible at math
the entire year has no impact on your
overall grade which is kind of weird
so literally there's no advantage to
being good at your at your craft at the
beginning of a school year
another big change teachers can no
longer consider non-material factors
when grading
things like turning in work on time and
classroom behavior will now instead
count to our students citizenship grade
not their academic grade that's
considered non-material now you don't
turn it in on time
that's not considered part of your
academic grade
also there is a suggestion that they
will
review potential student disparities
stemming from their zero tolerance
disciplinary policy on cheating
they're going to get rid of their
penalties for cheating because it turns
out that it might disproportionately
harm black people to punish people for
cheating
which again is a really racist notion
what only black people are cheating or
hispanic people are cheating or native
american people are cheating
in the san diego unified school district
but this sort of stuff is now running
rampant
throughout not only the intelligentsia
but through our state sanctioned systems
according to christopher ruffo writing
for the new york post today
at the king county library system a
private consulting firm called racial
equity consultants
recently held racially segregated
listening sessions to quote root out
institutional privileges and systemic
and aqua inequities
apparently there's a lot of
institutional racism in the library if
you reject that you're accused of
internalized racism
at the federal veterans administration
puget sound facility the local
leadership has launched a series of
racially segregated caucuses
for individuals who identify as white
and those who identify as
african-american or black or as people
of color
apparently these are racially segregated
sessions
the va were refused to provide comment
finally at the king county prosecutor's
office in seattle
the chief prosecutor dan satterberg and
senior staff have recently required
employees to sign an equity and social
justice pledge
and continued training for white
employees who must quote unquote do the
work
and learn the true history of racism in
our country
okay it turns out that this sort of
stuff
is going to drive a trump vote it will
and it should drive a trump vote because
if you're going to react to the complete
takeover
of the intellectual underpinnings of the
country by this anti-racist garbage
and the democrats have decided to go
along with it and not only go along with
it push it
foster it with your taxpayer dollars not
sure how many choices you have
and then there's the question of what
comes next if joe biden is elected we've
been covering this on the show i know
the media don't want to talk about what
happens after joe biden is elected
there's this bizarre notion that after
joe biden is elected
all wrongs are healed magically
everything bad in the country comes to
an end
and just good springs up everywhere in
much the same way that barack obama
deserved the nobel peace prize
for being breathing and also being
president of the united states once joe
biden is elected the work is done
there's nothing more to do but it turns
out there's an actual agenda that is
attached
to joe biden and it is a very very bad
agenda we'll get to that in one second
first let us talk about the fact that
right now a lot of people are staying
home
a lot of gyms across the country still
have extreme restrictions on what you
can and cannot do
at the gym more and more people are now
working out at home
which makes sense this is why you need
echelon echelon they've got a huge
lineup of connected fitness bikes
fitness mirrors rowing machines that
give you a fun
challenging workout from the comfort and
safety of your home in as little as 20
minutes
and get into the best shape of your life
and be active with the entire family the
world class instructors will motivate
you with daily live and on-demand
classes that are always available
when you need them and unlike their
competitors echelon is affordable for
everybody
the their ex1 connected fitness bike is
less than half the price of a peloton if
you've looked at those peloton ads
and you thought to yourself kind of fun
but looks like super duper expensive why
would i do that
well good news for you echelon can make
it happen for you my wife has been doing
the echelon classes they are excellent
she assures me
with echelon financing you can try them
out risk free for 30 days
zero down as little as 46 bucks per
month don't pay a ton
for a peloton instead go check out
echelon right now i've been using
echelon
myself that's how i got in this
incredible shape go check out echelon
right now the programs are fun the
equipment is fantastic and it's not
going to cost you an arm and a leg like
a peloton go to echelon fit
dot com slash ben that is
e-c-h-e-l-o-n-fit
dot com pen again echelon fit.com go
check them out
right now already in just a second we'll
get to more
from the biden agenda first 2020.
you may have noticed it's been an insane
year statues toppled coupled with
radical rioting looting in america
cities
it can feel at times like america is
coming apart right now it's a perfect
time to read my book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps i talk about the fact that there
are two perspectives on america one that
says we ought to stick together
and the other that says we really ought
to be ripped limb from limb because
america deserves it
my book how to destroy america in three
easy steps i think is the single best
window into what is going on in the
country
i'm not going to say it was prophetic
when i wrote it back in december but
it's kind of prophetic
it sort of predicted everything that was
going to happen in the country and
all of those problems are going to
outlast whatever this election is go
pick up a copy it is a great primer it
is a great educate people ask me all the
time what's a great history book i can
read to learn more about american
history
and american philosophy that's really
what my book is about go check it out
right now how to destroy america in
three easy steps makes a fantastic gift
particularly for high school and college
students how to destroy america in three
easy steps check it out right now also
in case you missed it we had another
fantastic episode of the sunday special
yesterday with megyn kelly we discussed
the media
bias against president trump we
discussed roger ailes in the movie
bombshell why she left fox
and the real question what's her take on
her interaction with trump during 2016.
so
head on over and watch at dailywire.com
or listen
on apple podcast spotify or wherever
else you get your podcast
also as with everything else in 2020
there's been a lot of drama with the
presidential debates but
we are ready for the next and final
debate this thursday join us at 8 45
pm eastern 5 45 p.m pacific for an
all-new episode of daily wire backstage
to watch debate with us
get our immediate live reaction to this
major political event even better
join daily wear right now as an insider
or all-access member get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all the debate coverage
live with us on our apple tv or our roku
app it's magical
where do members get well glad you asked
they get our articles they had free
access to all of our live broadcast and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show exclusive
readers past content available only to
daily wire members if you're considering
that all access membership you get to
join us
on all access live every night for
online and live stream discussions
you also get not one but two of these
magical leftist years tumblr
with your membership as well as early
sometimes exclusive access to new
daily wire products so go watch the
debate with us the final debate with us
on dailywire.com youtube and facebook
get 20 off your daily wire membership
with code debate when you
sign up today you are watching and
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all right so one of the questions we
ought to be asking ourselves is not just
what is the left going to do wrong in
terms of ideology but what are they
going to do wrong practically
members of the left members of the
democratic party continue to talk about
destroying america's institutions pete
booty judge over the weekend who is
now being widely touted as a top advisor
to joe biden
he was on fox news and he suggested that
we absolutely should pack the court he
calls it depoliticization of the court
because we now live
in 1984 where all terms have been
redefined
my views haven't changed i think
bipartisan reform
with the purpose of reducing the
politicization of the court
is a really promising idea let's also be
clear that a president can't just
snap their fingers and do it and most of
all
we don't want to allow this president to
change the subject which is what they're
always doing
we've got i mean there are all kinds of
interesting questions about the future
of the american judiciary
well okay so that's going to be fun it's
going to be fun to watch the democrats
try to pack the judiciary even as they
get rid of the filibuster
even as they add states to the senate if
you're worried about the institutional
infrastructure in the united states
trump ain't the danger to it
trump might like to in in the cockles of
his heart he might like
to overrun all institutional boundaries
he has yet to do so
seriously he really is not i mean the
fact is the legislature still has
enormous power
trump has used executive orders but less
so than barack obama did
trump has not in fact quashed the press
it is the democrats who are openly
threatening to destroy
institutions of the american government
they're threatening to destroy the
electoral college they're threatening to
destroy the senate they're threatening
to destroy the supreme court
they are threatening to make the
executive branch into the only branch
that matters that that's been part of
the long time goal going back to woodrow
wilson
mike pence correctly points out that we
do at some point deserve a straight
answer on court packing
but the good news is that the media will
ask and then when joe biden says i'll
tell you i'll tell you later
you know come on man come on i'll tell i
don't know i'll tell you later come on
man
then they're just they go back to sleep
here's mike pence pointing this out
now joe biden says uh he's going to tell
the american people
what he'll do after judge barrett is
confirmed
in a week or so even though millions of
americans are voting right now
well come on man
the american people deserve a straight
answer joe
when you're running for the highest
office in the land the american people
deserve to know if you're going to
respect the highest court in the land
okay the answer is he's not going to get
that answer because the media are
utterly uninterested in anything
revolving around joe biden they're also
uninterested in his economic plans
the wall street journal editorial board
has a piece today talking about the cost
of bidenomics
same joe biden has truly kept the
campaign focused on cover 19 and
president trump
which has helped him avoid having to
talk much about his own policies that's
especially true of his economic
proposals
a new study out sunday from the hoover
institution shows well that it will have
a damaging impact on growth
job creation and household income biden
often cites moody's the credit rating
service for saying his economic plan
will yield faster growth and more jobs
wall street he likes to say when he
mentions moody's as if that's a
conservative stamp of approval
even as he claims trump is a captive of
wall street but everyone knows most
economists at today's big financial
institutions have a keynesian bias
that posits consumer demand and
government spending as the main drivers
of growth right this is
certainly true of moody's and the fact
is that
a huge number of quote unquote
economists on wall street are very much
in favor of the government
taxing more and spending out the wazoo
because they believe that spending is
going to jog the economy to new and
great heights despite the fact
that that's not actually what has
happened here barack obama spent money
like a crazy person and the economy was
incredibly slow trump cut regulations
and spent money like a crazy person
and the economy grew incredibly fast it
wasn't about the spending of the money
it was about the cutting of the
regulations it was about the lowering of
the taxes it was about the feeling
that trump was not going to change the
rules on businesses around the country
based on whatever the political whim of
the moment was the wall street journal
says
we're not predicting a depression if
biden wins the election on dire economic
predictions trump is the mirror image
of paul krugman on the left because
trump keeps saying there will be a
depression if cro
if if biden wins the data show the us
economy is recovering from the pandemic
shutdowns faster than most economists
predicted
democrats may attempt to portray the
economy as a disaster that requires
trillions in new spending but biden
would inherit
an economy with strong growth momentum
the housing market is booming small
business sentiment is bullish
manufacturing is on the rebound once a
coven 19 vaccine is approved and better
therapies become more widely available
the economy should take off as even
democratic governors ease their
lockdowns
the issue however is whether biden's
policies will nurture this strong
recovery or slow it down
this is where the hoover study comes in
it examines the democrats proposals on
health insurance taxes energy and
regulation
the authors our economist timothy
fitzgerald kevin hassett cody kellen and
casey mulligan
both hassett and mulligan were members
of the council of economic advisors in
the trump white house
but then the boosters of bidenomics are
veterans of the clinton obama
administrations
overall the authors estimate that the
biden agenda if fully implemented would
reduce full-time equivalent
employment per person by about three
percent the capital stock per person by
some 15
and real gdp per capita by more than
eight percent compared to the
congressional budget office estimates
for these variables in 2030
this means there will be 4.9 million
fewer working americans 2.6 trillion
dollars less in gdp and 6 500 bucks less
in median household income by 2030.
okay well that's a lot of money out of
your pocket
the analytical details are especially
helpful on energy costs and the
so-called labor wedge against hiring
that have received little attention
biden's plans to promote electric
vehicles and phase out fossil fuels
go beyond anything obama proposed to
take just one example
the electrification of most passenger
cars would increase the per capita
demand for electric power by 25
even as more than 70 of baseline
electric power from fossil fuels would
go offline
so you'd require enormous subsidies in
other words they're getting rid of
electric power plants at the same time
they need more electricity
or consider the expansion of the aca and
medicare for people above 60 versus 65
now
the subsidies affect the incentive to
work authors estimate the aca changes
would increase the average marginal tax
rate on labor by 2.4 percentage points
that's nearly half as much as the six
percentage points from the original aca
biden is also proposing substantial
increases in business tax rates that
will raise the cost of capital
all of this will eventually end up being
imposed down to the worker
biden would raise capital costs by
phasing down bonus depreciation in the
2017 tax reform you would raise labor
costs by imposing
a 12.4 social security payroll tax to
income above 400 thousand dollars
that threshold is not indexed for
inflation so it applied to ever more
americans as the years go by
and none of this is good for the economy
so again there's a lot about a biden
administration that'll be bad ranging
from attacks on institutions to economic
plans
it's his willingness to count out to
china and iran there's a lot that's bad
there
now the big problem for trump is that
trump has not been able to make biden
the focus of this campaign and he
refuses to make biden the focus
of this campaign he loves the rallies he
loves being a stand-up comedian
but the fact is that every time he does
a rally and is a stand-up comedian
and he says things that draw headlines
he may enjoy that it may jazz up the
base
but it explicitly allows joe biden to
escape any sort of questioning because
the media
just zoom in on trump they just redirect
the camera away from biden and back to
trump
so instead of him going out there and
doing just an hour-long rally just
asking over and over and over
what's going on with hunter and joe
instead it's just random
weird distractions and overall claims
about locking people up
so trump did a rally over the weekend
where uh he he literally
like trump he's a troll and it's one of
the things people love about him
is that he's willing to troll a media
that has been trolling the right for too
long
but it's hard for trolls to win
elections it is trolls have a tough time
motivating people in the middle anybody
be on the base it's tough to get
motivated so here is trump
i mean this is very funny stuff i mean
i'm not going to pretend it's not funny
i'm also not going to do what so many
people do which is what when trump says
something that he said before
and people say he's reached a new low
it's a new low nope same low as ever
same exact low there is no new low for
trump it is not as though he just keeps
digging that pip that pit has a bottom
the bottom is where we are we've been
there for four years trump has been
absolutely consistent
he has not changed one iota here is
trump being trump
[Applause]
why don't you drive him crazy just say
12 more years right
12 more years okay so again very funny
line i get it and people love it on his
side
and then it just gives the the democrats
an excuse to say that trump is never
gonna leave
office and he's violating institutional
norms everyone knows he's joking
doesn't matter it allows for another
media cycle about this stuff then
trump was doing this rally and and he
and the crowd started chanting lock her
up about
about gretchen whitmer who's the
governor of michigan now of course
whitmer's
lockdown policies have been awful i mean
truly truly bad her covet policies were
really really bad
but there's also a story out there right
now that she was being targeted by a
terror group for actual kidnapping and
maybe murder
and so when the crowd starts chanting
lock her up about gretchen whitmer and
then trump says
lock them all up like is that a headline
that you need right now
really like truly again this is
political malpractice
the democrats would terminate our
recovery
with a draconian unscientific lockdown
like your governor is doing right now
for everybody except
for her husband no it's so badly hurting
you stay
okay and trump kind of lets that go uh
and then he suggested that joe and
hunter biden and the clintons should
should be locked up this is all just is
different
he eat a bunch of rallies over the
weekend none of this is useful none of
it's a new bottom i'm not gonna pretend
i'm newly offended by any of this
i find all of it equally stupid and
equally offensive i just don't i don't
think it's worthwhile i don't think it
is a smart tactic
i don't think that it has anything to do
with the world of reality gretchen
whitmer is not going to jail joe biden
in hunter biden no criminal activity has
been proved they're not going to jail
hillary clinton she did something
criminal it was let off the hook by
james comey she ain't going to jail
is this sort of stuff useful i mean just
for a second forget about how much you
dislike the people he's talking about is
it useful for him to be doing this in
the last couple of weeks of a
presidential campaign
that biden family and others but that
biden family is corrupt
it's a corrupt family
[Applause]
and with me and my kids let me tell you
my kids
i'll tell you something though i just
lock them up you should lock them up
lock up the buttons lock up hillary
okay so that's playing the hit there's
only one problem he's got a debate on
thursday
and you know this is now going to come
up are you now you know that kristen
welker who is uh
the moderator in this particular case
she is um
she's definitely gonna ask biden what is
his favorite flavor of ice cream and
then she's gonna ask trump
on what basis he is suggesting that his
political opponents ought to be locked
up
again trump says things that sound like
they violate institutional norms
and they violate rhetorical norms i
think that is certainly true i think he
violates rhetorical norms on a daily
basis he's been doing this
since 2015. as far as institutional
morals democrats are certainly more of a
threat to institutional norms
so the case for trump really is the case
against biden and the case for what the
trump administration has done
not the case for trump personally and so
when people say how could conservatives
vote for trump i mean look at the man
look at his character look at all this
the answer is the alternative sucks the
alternative is terrible the alternative
is an ideology
of wokism that is completely damaging to
the american ideal the alternative is
horrible policy on the part of joe biden
the alternative stinks and also the
trump administration has done a lot of
good things which is why when i watched
the mike pence como harris debate
and you just watched pence defend most
of the trump agenda you thought to
yourself
if this were the trump agenda without a
lot of the
crazy this is a winning agenda right
here
okay so with that said over the weekend
i've said before
many times i've said before that i plan
on voting for trump in this election
cycle and i do i plan on voting for
trump in this election cycle
but i didn't vote for trump in 2016.
right i mean i was very obvious about
the fact i didn't vote for trump i
didn't say that it was a sin like some
people did vote for trump
i didn't suggest that it was bad vote
for trump i said i fully understand why
you would vote for trump to stop hillary
clinton
i can't do it in 2016. and i made my
reasons very apparent at the time
well now obviously i'm planning to vote
for trump in 2020.
so over the weekend i cut a video that i
think
tries to explain why that is what has
changed
so here is a video why i'm voting for
donald trump i think it lays out the
case for why conservatives
ought to vote for trump here's what it
sounds like
i did not vote for donald trump in 2016.
i am voting for donald trump in 2020.
there are three reasons i'm gonna vote
for donald trump in 2020 when i didn't
four years ago
first i was simply wrong about donald
trump on policy
second i wasn't really wrong about
donald trump on character but whatever
damage he was gonna do
has already been done and it's not gonna
help if i don't vote for him this time
and third
most importantly the democrats have lost
the minds so first of all
donald trump has governed pretty
conservatively i thought he would not be
conservative in his governance
i was just wrong on that donald trump
radically cut regulation
he actually saw reductions in the number
of man hours dedicated to dealing with
regulation
for the first time in a long time under
donald trump he appointed originalist
judges to the best of his ability we're
talking dozens of them
textualist originalist judges who
actually care about the role of the
judiciary
he cut taxes jogging in the economy
raising its heights not seen
in half a century the lost unemployment
rate in half a century people
having their wages rise at the bottom of
the spectrum
he appointed pro-life people to the
executive branch and pursued pro-life
policy via executive order he dumped out
of the idiotic
paris accords which were useless and
counterproductive he dumped the even
more idiotic and evil iran deal which
gave money to the iranian mullahs
to use for terrorism as john kerry
freely admitted donald trump crushed
isis
he killed all baghdadi he killed kasem
solomonia donald trump is the first
president of my lifetime not to start
any new wars which is a kind of big
thing
he moved the american embassy in israel
to jerusalem he broke into the first
meaningful peace deals there
in three decades in the middle east he
cracked down on china in unprecedented
ways
he's resisted using the federal
government to control everybody's life
during cove that's a big
thing this is the biggest government
power grab of my lifetime and trump
refused to do it donald trump restored
due process on college campuses because
he actually
cares about due process or at least as
secretary of education does contrary to
popular opinion
donald trump has not actually threatened
the institutions the fact is
that donald trump may have been hemmed
in by his own people whatever the
rationale he has not threatened the
press
he has not threatened the legislature he
has not used the executive branch in
nearly as powerful ways as barack obama
did trump hasn't been as conservative as
i would like on everything he's spent
way too much money like oodles too much
money i actually care about that stuff
his perspective on trade is a zero-sum
game i think it's wrong-headed
he's still signed into law the usmca
which is a pretty good trade deal but
these are problems i've had with a
variety of republicans including george
w bush
trump has governed overall in a far more
conservative fashion than w
on policy he is the most conservative
president of my lifetime on policy
of course ronald reagan left office when
i was four years old second
times change when i said i wouldn't vote
for trump in 2016
i was worried about three things one
policy again i was wrong
second i was worried about the
soul-sucking of the republican party to
approve bad behavior
people nodding and grinning at bad stuff
trump did a lot of that has happened
and third i was worried about toxicity
down ballot right losing house seats
losing senate seats blowing out the
republican party with minorities and
women and young people
a lot of that has manifested but here's
the thing it's already manifested
and me not voting for trump in 2020
doesn't stop that from manifesting like
i've been very very clear
on my feelings about donald trump's
character i have serious reservations to
say the least
trump has some good qualities raise a
hammer in search of a nail sometimes
he hits a nail it's super satisfying and
sometimes he hits a baby and it is far
less satisfying
trump hitting the media is often
justified i mean the media
have exposed themselves as just a pure
dumpster fire of leftist garbage they've
treated him as an enemy from the very
first day they have promulgated false
narratives
they've lied about things that he has
said they have taken
the worst interpretation of everything
he could possibly have said that doesn't
mean that trump hasn't been vindictive
or petty or immoral he does all those
things trump being unable to focus and
willing to jump on any rake
is not just immoral it is very often
stupid and counterproductive i mean
you know my opinion on this everybody
knows okay deep down in the holes
of your heart no matter how much you
love trump
everybody knows the trump administration
with trump on teleprompter more often
and less on twitter
would be in a position to win the 2020
election more easily everybody also
knows that trump's tweets damage him
with people who don't already love him
all of that is true right but
all of it is not changing there's a
group of people out there who every time
trump tweets something
newly stupid they get newly enraged i
think most americans
basically this is all baked into the
cake at this point i think it's
important
deeply important for conservatives to
criticize trump when he requires it
when trump does something bad we should
say it out loud we shouldn't hide that
and that's why i've been calling balls
and strikes on trump as a president
since the day he was elected
but 2020 is not 2016. everything that is
bad about trump
is already part of the system it's
already part of the new normal for
better or for worse
and me avoiding voting for him in 2020
doesn't change that third
and most importantly the democrats have
lost their minds
they've lost their minds so members of
the mainstream media
so members of our bureaucracy some
members of academia
these people must not be allowed the
mechanisms of power
our most crucial institutions from
corporate america
to the universities they've been
corrupted top to bottom and giving them
power
over your lives more power over your
lives huge
mistake the democrats are no longer the
party even of hillary clinton or barack
obama they're the party of bernie
sanders
and they're just wearing around the mask
of joe biden they're the party of
rashida talib and
omar joe biden is a potemkin village of
a candidate he is not a bulwark against
radicalism he is a facade for it
everybody knows it that's why bernie is
touting him as the most progressive
presidential candidate
since fdr there's a reason that noam
chomsky is on board with joe biden
right i mean if you just watch this
stuff it should scare the hell out of
you today's democratic party is not even
the democratic party of barack obama
circa 2008.
barack obama circa 2008 supported
traditional marriage
barack obama circa 2008 was not openly
in favor
of packing the courts or getting rid of
the filibuster barack obama in 2008
used to speak about personal
responsibility sometimes like all of
this is just gone the democratic party
is now the party of radicalism
the simple mandate for the democrats is
this they now believe in cramming down
their perspective on
everyone they can via any force that
they can control they believe that you
should be forced by law to violate your
religious beliefs if it conflicts with
their social views
they believe that the science says we
have to destroy the free market in the
name of the environment they say that
unborn babies
aren't babies that men can be women and
if you disagree with any of that you are
a bigot
and you're a homophobe and you're a
terrible person they believe that your
right to keep and bear arms should be
heavily infringed if not outright
abolished they believe that due process
comes second to intersectional identity
that we shouldn't judge you as an
individual we should judge you based on
your
racial group they believe that america
is systemically racist rooted in sin and
evil founded in 1619 not in 1776
they believe that every single disparity
in america can be chalked up
to racism and bigotry and america
sucking they believe in racial sexual
sexual orientation
quotas overt discrimination they believe
in a hierarchy of victimhood if you're
low on that hierarchy of victimhood you
should shut up if you're high on the
hierarchy victimhood you can say
whatever the hell you want you will
never be held
accountable they believe that economic
freedom should be curbed in the name of
income equality they care far less
about growth and prosperity than they do
about some bizarre notion that equality
is its own
good they're complicit in a culture war
on anybody who disagrees they seek to
ruin anybody who stands in their way
and they'll activate the media they'll
activate social media they'll activate
their friends in academia to get all of
that done
meanwhile they'll make room for antifa
and black lives matter they will cheer
the rioting and the looting or at least
they'll go along with it and refuse to
condemn it but if you go to church
during a pandemic you are a danger to
society if you go to grandma's funeral
you're super dangerous
but if you are out there rioting and
looning and burning things
that's just the philosophy guys it's not
a movement it's not an organization as
joe biden said they literally will not
even condemn antifa
okay antifa is a terrorist organization
they will not condemn it
they will not condemn black lives matter
protests that escalate into rioting and
looting
they think that there's no relationship
whatsoever between an ideology that
suggests that america is a root evil and
that every institution in american life
is infected with that evil and the
writing and the looting
on foreign policy the democrats want to
kowtow to iran they want to re-enter the
garbage paris accords they want to make
nice with china
they've threatened to destroy the
electoral college pack the supreme court
abolish the filibuster add states by
simple majority to vote democrat they
say they'll use impeachment as a purely
political tool
in fact they've even said they want a
congressional committee to use the 25th
amendment to get rid of a sitting
president
they seek to centralize all power in the
executive branch and they hope to
overrun the powers of the states they're
aided in all of this by corporations
the mainstream media and pretty much
anybody else they can get their hands on
they've created a social structure
dedicated to ostracizing anybody who
descends on leftist dogma if you vote
for trump you are evil your friends
should stop talking to you
you should stop talking to your own
parents maybe you should be fired
certainly people should stop treating
you like a human being
so here's the deal i'm voting for trump
you don't have to love trump's character
you don't have to like his twitter
account to vote for him you don't have
to approve of the crazy or bad things
that he says
or the way he often acts but if you care
about the constitution and economic
freedom and the security of the united
states
you really don't have a whole hell of a
lot of choice you should vote for trump
you should certainly vote against joe
biden and a democratic party that is
running
completely off the rails and now
threatens the integrity of the republic
if they are given the levers of power
alrighty so
there you have it the case for voting
for trump well
tomorrow we'll get into much much more
preparation for the debate
joe biden apparently going into hiding
all the way until thursday because he
knows the media will never ask him
a tough question this race right now is
fraught it looks like the polls may be
starting to narrow we can hope
at least a little bit i will again
encourage the president of the united
states to stop scraping the bottom of
the barrel because
not only is it morally wrong it is
politically unfeasible and
and and foolish the fact is that
this is an incredibly important election
because the direction of the country
is now being decided it's not being
decided on what the direction of the
country was four years ago nobody has a
time machine
it's not about 2008 it's about right now
where are the democrats going to take us
if they win not only the presidency but
the senate the answer is no place good
we'll be back here tomorrow with much
much more or later today with a couple
additional hours of content i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton